[Música]
hoje a gente vai conversar um pouquinho
sobre educação financeira e pra começar
eu gostaria de mostrar pra vocês uma
imagem que eu acho muito importante é a
chamada corrida dos ratos que a gente
está vendo ali ver os ratinhos
eles sempre estão ali em busca da
felicidade só que a felicidade sempre
está na próxima curva então eles
precisam trabalhar mais
eles precisam ganhar mais dinheiro
depois comprar mais coisas e o processo
se repete
veja nós vivemos em uma corrida dos
ratos porque a gente sempre contra a
criança
você precisa estudar mais para que você
possa se formar aí você se forma precisa
estudar mais para conseguir emprego pra
que você consegue um emprego pra você
conseguir ter dinheiro e dinheiro para
que a comprar coisas ea gente fica nesse
ciclo todo mês
veja como é que a gente sai dessa
corrida dos ratos né
com educação financeira mas veja quando
a gente fala de educação financeira
geralmente têm um tom pejorativo ali as
pessoas geralmente fala assim a esse
cara quer ensinar os outros e mão de
vaca né de pão duro ou se não ele é
ganancioso ele só pensa em dinheiro
sempre tem um tom pejorativo ali né
mas por exemplo vocês sabem qual é o
maior motivo de divórcios no brasil
vocês devem imaginar né infidelidade
será que eu errei vezes o slide ele não
é a chamada infidelidade financeira que
quer dizer isso né
um casal em geral sempre tem um que é
mais poupador
e o outro é mais gastador e o casal como
todas as pessoas não conversam sobre o
dinheiro
e aí o que ocorre é um gasto a mais do
que o outro ou um bastão escondido do
outro e aí começam os conflitos
então esse costuma ser um dos maiores
motivos de divórcio no brasil
principalmente ou a falta de diálogo de
dinheiro ou simplesmente a ausência de
dinheiro
bem eu vou conversar um pouquinho com
vocês aqui sobre a minha experiência de
dar aulas de educação financeira uma
instituição pública gratuita federal
aqui no cefet que é o cefet petrópolis
que fica bem no centro
da cidade para começar eu gostaria de
fazer um certo em exercício de
imaginação que vocês imaginam um grupo
de pessoas que provocam instalar
brincando com um determinado jogo
se aquele jogo por um acaso lhe
interessar a primeira pergunta que
geralmente a gente faz a seguinte quais
são as regras desse jogo é geralmente a
primeira pergunta porque se você não
souber em as regras do jogo
muito provavelmente vocês vão perder o
jogo até mesmo os azarões
a eles foi dito quais eram as regras ou
seja que quero dizer
essa vida que a gente tem ela é composta
por várias regras e essas regras não
lhes são ditas a gente não conhece as
regras financeiras
veja a gente fala sobre juros a gente
fala sobre taxa selic cdi e bolsa de
valores que que é isso
aonde que foi apresentado isso pra gente
então a minha proposta justamente é
trazer isso para o universo de colégios
e universidades
já está mais do que na hora de a gente
conversar sobre dinheiro bem para
começar eu vou mostrar um pouquinho de
como começou esse assunto pra mim o que
vocês estão vendo aí um mini game
quem aí década de 90 conhece bem e daí
sair era uma febre
todo mundo queria comprar um mini game e
eu como uma boa criança de sete anos
eu também queria comprar um mini game à
época eu te ganhava aquele dinheiro do
lanche governo até falava que eu era
mesmo de vaca porque eu juntava aquele
dinheiro deixava de comer para juntar
aquele meu dinheirinho pra comprar esse
mini game e acontecia eu ia até a loja
o valor do mínimo tinha aumentado aí eu
juntava dinheiro de novo e até a loja o
valor ser aumentado de novo eu fui
infelizmente apresentado ao conceito de
inflação e à época começa a liberdade de
90 era a hiperinflação no brasil e se
esse mini game cópia mente não consegui
comprar por mim vias próprias né então
de alguma maneira eu tive que recorrer
ao dinheiro de alguém dinheiro dos pais
no caso da minha mãe ela sempre teve um
bom um diálogo comigo relação ao
dinheiro etc
mas é uma coisa muito interessante
seguinte em geral a gente não faz
sobre dinheiro e as pessoas os adultos
não falam sobre dinheiro com as crianças
já imaginaram como é que uma criança vê
o dinheiro
veja ela viu a mãe indo até um caixa
eletrônico
bota um pedaço de plástico e sai
dinheiro dele
aquilo ali é uma fonte infinita né
dinheiro ou cartão de crédito pior ainda
é um pedaço de plástico em que ela usa o
mai o pai ea mãe falando o seguinte olha
parcela e 56 vezes a criança nem sequer
sabe dividir e tá ouvindo esses
conceitos
então os adultos às vezes limitam a
dizer o seguinte olha eu não tenho
dinheiro ou a clássica das respostas
na volta a gente compra ou seja preciso
falar um pouco mais sobre dinheiro
inclusive com crianças porque as
crianças elas de fato elas exemplo dos
pais
então a gente tem que sempre pensar que
tipo de exemplo dando pro meu filho a
gente tem que conversar isso inclusive
com nossos filhos
bem eu obviamente pelo assunto você deve
imaginar que a minha formação foi em
administração ou talvez em economia
a minha formação inteira foi física eu
tenho graduação mestrado doutorado em
física pela pj mas a educação financeira
pra mim sempre foi um grande hobby
porque eu ouvia falar sobre bolsa de
valores é que eu queria saber mais sobre
isso é uma das principais coisas que eu
percebi se você quer aprender de fato
algo é realmente você tem que se
envolver com aquilo você tem que entrar
naquilo bem a minha família de maneira
geral ela é bem comum
tá meu pai é físico e os dois irmãos são
físicos
minhas duas irmãs são matemáticas ea
minha esposa física
então é uma família inteira de exatas né
e obviamente quando a gente está na
física o caminho natural é sermos
professores ea minha primeira grande
experiência como professor foi quando
tinha 25 anos estava no meio do meu
doutorado eu tinha uma turma de mais ou
menos 120 alunos
você imagina como muito semelhante ao
histórico até aqui 120 alunos numa pauta
de engenharia mecânica
bem quando está na frente das duas uma
ou você se apavora
ou você encara aquela situação uma das
coisas que me chocou foi o seguinte
quando comecei a falar
todos eles estavam prestando atenção em
mim prestava atenção em cada movimento
cada coisa que eu falava e aí eu percebi
o seguinte o o que é ser um professor
professor não é aquele que transmite
professor não é rádio para ficar
transmitindo coisas
o professor está ali para trazer uma
certa vivência uma interação com os
alunos
então quando via ser professor aqui do
cefet petrópolis
eu conversava muito com meus colegas
sobre esse assunto virou um vício
confesso eu sempre conversava sobre
educação financeira sobre investimentos
e 101 das coisas que eu notei é que a
questão da titulação da pessoa de
mestrado doutorado interessa não está
vinculado diretamente à formação dela
como educador financeiro ou seja ela não
tem uma formação não conhece
investimentos e nem sequer sabe que
existe vida além da poupança
então eu pensei o seguinte poxa física
importante matemática importante
biologia importante história todas essas
ações são importantes porque não falar
sobre educação financeira ali na
instituição no cefet
a minha primeira turma foi composta
basicamente por alunos do próprio cefet
eles tinham por volta de 1920 anos torno
disso todos os alunos de graduação
o mais interessante é o seguinte quando
eles chegavam na o curso
a primeira pergunta que eles faziam era
a seguinte como é que eu faço pra ficar
rico
assim simples direto e aí eu gosto de
fazer o seguinte exercício com vocês
aqui favor
levanta a mão aqui quem gostaria de ser
rico vários né
mas o mais importante é o seguinte e
como é que você define ser rico o que é
ser rico porque todo mundo quer ser rico
mas como é que você define ser rico e é
geralmente as pessoas falam ah é ter
muito dinheiro mas não vamos lá
quantifique isso
o que é ser rico aí que vem a questão
cada um deles dizia uma coisa diferente
de uma definição diferente ser rico e
isso essa pergunta geral ela diz muito
sobre nós porque tendemos a ser muito
imediatista
a gente quer soluções rápidas a gente
quer fórmulas mágicas como é que eu faço
pra ganhar muito em pouco tempo é sempre
essa questão bem
a segunda coisa que eu dizia era o
seguinte olha é fundamental que a gente
tenha metas metas para diferentes prazos
isso é fundamental porque quando a gente
chegar à meta que a gente faz dobra meta
né
mas não só isso essas metas para
diferentes prazos veja curto prazo médio
prazo e longo prazo porque isso é tão
importante né
geralmente a gente ouvir a seguinte
comentário olha se você deixar de tomar
cafezinho daqui a 30 anos você vai ter
tantos mil reais
alguém se imagina sem tomar cafezinho
você imagina um professor sem café
se não existe certo essa fala é péssima
porque te dá intenção de que você deve
se privar de algo pra só usufruir lá no
futuro muito distante e não é assim né a
gente precisa dessas metas diferentes
prazo atingir uma meta você pode
construir um novo sonho e é muito
importante você dar nomes aos sonhos bem
quando abriu o curso agora para o
público em geral foi um sucesso porque
assim em dois dias as inscrições
acabaram e foram mais de 350 inscritos
só pelo cefet a gente tem uma limitação
um máximo de 50 pessoas e o público foi
de 17 anos há 70 anos a e era um público
muito diverso
o mais interessante é que no meio do
curso eu me lembro bem que um dos alunos
falou o seguinte felipe tudo você está
falando muito interessante questão de
investimentos etc
porém eu tenho um probleminha eu possuo
dívidas bem a pessoa quando disse isso
ela sempre fala com certo
constrangimento porque obviamente né é
necessário ter coragem de falar
possui dívidas a pessoa passe
constrangida pra dizer isso mas veja
mais de 60 milhões de brasileiros
possuem algum tipo de dívida hoje são um
fato
então o que eu sempre digo é se você
possui dívidas
é muito importante você negociar as
dívidas mas falar é fácil né negocia
veja a negociar isso envolve
necessariamente pelo menos duas pessoas
mas uma das pessoas trabalha com aquilo
ela conhece todo aquele vocabulário e
você então você precisa também conhecer
aquelas regras do jogo para poder sentar
à mesa para negociar tratar aquela sua
dívida e saná lá e se você não possui
dívidas poxa legal formam uma reserva de
emergência e o que quer dizer isso eu
falar o seguinte
suponha que por um acaso você perca seu
emprego hoje
quanto tempo você conseguiria manter o
seu padrão de vida ou da sua família aos
meus alunos falavam assim ele o felipão
acha que cinco dias
outro falando algumas semanas ou talvez
dois meses e isso é fato emergências
ocorrem isso realmente ocorre e aí
porque você tem que ter uma reserva de
emergência porque na hora que essas
emergências ocorrem a gente faz mão de
préstimos com juros muito altos e acaba
enganando todo bem eu comecei aqui minha
palestra falando muito sobre a questão
da felicidade não sempre tem essa
questão da felicidade com relação ao
dinheiro se dinheiro traz felicidade de
certo né
é esse é um fato que eu sei que não se
esse dinheiro de fato traz felicidade
mas é fato que a ausência do dinheiro
pode trazer a infelicidade uma aluna
minha justamente essa de 70 anos
ela me falou uma coisa muito importante
ela falou felipe é por muitas vezes a
gente cuida dos nossos filhos
a gente cuida dos nossos metros mas
nenhum momento a gente cuida de nós
mesmos
eu acho que é dessa palestra que eu
percebi que de fato a gente tem que
tratar mais da gente pensar que daqui a
pouco daqui a 30 anos estaremos uma
certa idade ea gente precisa ter esse
cuidado durante esse processo
então pra finalizar esse conceito de
felicidade
cada um tem o seu né mas eu prefiro
finalizar com uma definição do professor
clóvis de barros filho que diz o
seguinte a felicidade é um instante o
momento que você gostaria que se
repetisse
eu gostaria que esse momento aqui se
eternizasse muito obrigado
[Aplausos]